we tell teachers that you shouldn't be
the sage on the stage but you should
actually be the guide on the side but
they really don't have the tools that
are necessary to really make that
possible to date
one of the big differences with khan
academy is that we're not trying to
just replicate the
existing systems using technology to
augment the way existing instruction is
done we're fundamentally thinking about
reinventing
instruction we've gotten letters from
teachers who said hey you've already
given the lecture on l'hopital's rule or
the unit circle so instead of me giving
the basic lecture on that and then
assigning homework we flip the model i'm
assigning the lecture for them to watch
at home and then they can watch what i
assign but then if they have some
questions they can remediate and watch
stuff that was taught in previous
sections or if they're bored they can
move ahead and and go as advanced as
they want and then when they go into the
classroom they can actually do problems
they actually do their homework in the
classroom you know we have this teacher
dashboard right now where it shows
all of the students and all of the
concepts and within a glance the teacher
can see who's mastered what who's
struggling with what where each student
is in their development and learning
they can see in real time where all the
students are in aggregate the coach will
be able to see who's stuck they can
click on any one of the concepts and see
exactly what the students have been up
to buy problem they can see how long
they spent on each problem did they get
it right or wrong did they watch the
video before or after working on that
problem if they saw that they got a
problem wrong they can actually click on
that
part and see the exact problem that they
got wrong so they can really diagnose
and do very focused interventions to
kind of make sure that all the students
are progressing
in every other industry if you want to
diagnose why something is not working
you try to get as much data on it as
possible so that you can really say okay
i need to just tighten that part right
over there what we're trying to do is
give teachers that level of data we can
start to impact individuals directly
without having to change the entire
educational system to roll it out it's
actually super simple
it's all web-based it's all free so
literally if a school has internet
connectivity and has computers any type
of computer they're ready to start at
one plus one and get to calculus
you